I'll tell you my wife asked me she said
who
is your hall pass and I said you should
go first
and she said I'll pass a Brad Pitt
by the way for me it's a great choice to
me there's no bad pit either pick a
movie Legends of the pulpit money ball
pit fight ball pit pit it's all good pit
there's no bad pit right no bad pit and
so I said it's a great choice and she
said who's yours I said uh Janet who
lives next door
[Music]
hey if I must shoot my shot it's going
to be in reality everybody you know what
I'm saying
Brad Pitt is not you I know that
for sure
but Friday night bottle of wine I'm not
gonna lie to you I think I got a shot
with Janet I really do foreign